[Musique]
nous sommes très heureux aussi vous
aussi bien sur le plan de la qualité au
niveau de l'environnement la qualité de
l'architecturé du centre et la création
d'emplois et la taxe professionnelle que
ça peut amener la ville des classes et
d'une superbe réalisation étroitement
associé au projet depuis le départ il ya
quatre ans la municipalité des clés peut
en effet se réjouir de l'arrivée de ce
centre commercial nouvelle vague
d'abord parce que c'est toute l'entrée
de la ville qui est ainsi complètement
métamorphosé son aspect architectural
particulièrement étudiée lui vaut
d'ailleurs le premier label valorparc
décerné en france ensuite parce qu'il
vaut 315 emplois dont plus d'une
centaine de créations pures nous avons
voulu faire quelque chose de très
différent de ce que l'on trouve
habituellement les entrées de ville et
dans les commerces de périphérie
c'est à dire que vous avez derrière vous
énormément dans scènes de périphérie
mais qui sont toutes reliées ensemble
par une promenade couverte est à la fois
découverte
cette promenade est longée par une
rivière la locomotive de ce nouveau
centre spécialisé maison et d'écossé
castorama qui a quitté plaisir pour
s'implanter sur une surface plus grande
huit autres enseignes se partagent le
second bâtiment dont cultura spécialisée
dans les loisirs créatifs mais aussi les
livres les disques et le multi média
cultura qui ouvre ici son premier
magasin dans les yvelines
quant à la concurrence avec le récent
skywest on affirme ici n'avoir aucune
inquiétude
on a fait plusieurs plusieurs dizaines
de son âge tous les sondages font
apparaître des
caractérisé pollution aux hydrocarbures
pour mener à bien les travaux de
terrassement un contrôle permanent sera
donc assurée par un expert un contrôle
visuel et olfactif est prévu lors de
chaque coup de pioche est l'examen
pourrait aussi être plus poussée dans
certains cas parfois quand il ya des
doutes
lui il analysera avec un petit
laboratoire portatif la pollution donc
là c'est un peu plus long parce que les
cadences sont pas les mêmes donc on
considère en moyenne qu'on va mettre un
mois et demi produits de trois semaines
pour terrasser toutes ces terres
polluées ou pas ce cadeau de l'ancienne
entreprise présente sur le site la
communauté d'agglomération s'en serait
bien passé une procédure judiciaire est
en cours mais le montant de la facture
près de 800000 euros et pour le moment a
avancé une somme importante qui
s'explique par l'acheminement des terres
polluées en fonction du degré de
pollution qu'on va constater en phase de
terrassement
on enverra tel ou tel camion dans une
décharge soit de classe 1 classe 2 e
classe iii ou bio centre donc ces quatre
types de décharge qui vont traiter ce
type de pollution
ces aménagements auront également une
autre conséquence inévitable un retard
de livraison jusqu'en 2008
l'école de musique aurait dû voir le
jour le 12 mai de cette année en même
temps que la salle de concert et les
studios de répétition situé juste en
face
[Musique]